sophie turner is baby bumpin i'm so
excited about it
on Saturday the Game of Thrones star
showed off her cute growing baby bump
during a joyride with her hubby Joe
Jonas that's the 24 year old keeping it
cool in the LA heat in a curve hugging
purple dress pink shades and face masks
and there's Joe casual in a bright blue
t-shirt shades and a Bob Marley face
mask it's just like the best to pull it
the best person to calm me down and keep
me calm news broke that the two were
expecting their first baby together back
in February but Sofie has kept her cute
little baby bump under wraps
sporting looser fitting clothing until
now during a recent appearance on Sirius
XM's hits one celebrity session Joe
opened up about how quarantine has been
going for the couple amid the corona
virus pandemic we're having a good time
I mean like you know we got married last
year so we're we're new to this so we're
still enjoying that time and also we
were on tour for well it seems like more
than a year so being home is kind of
nice the two started dating in 2016 you
posted a picture of mr. Joe Jonas on
Instagram people called an Instagram
official what do you like about spending
time with him we go eat some really good
food together
nice Brussels sprouts got engaged in
2017 you said you're the happiest you've
ever been right now what are the keys to
having a happy relationship in Hollywood
because that's not easy you seem to be
doing it beautifully it's all the same
just love and be loved and tie the knot
in a surprise wedding in Vegas in 2019
I'd do about 5 minutes for the wedding
ceremony he actually knew somebody was
getting married we didn't know who et
exclusively spoke to Jessie Garon aka
Reverend Elvis Presley the lucky man who
officiated their Vegas I Do's had
blocked off the whole chapel from 8:00
to 12:00 and they didn't tell us who it
was they wouldn't tell us was till I got
here and I actually saw him in person
how long ago did they block it off not a
week ago so they decided about a week
ago so they knew about a week ago yes
sir
Joe's brothers Nick and Kevin were right
by his side both serving as best man the
brothers did the best man they got a
very important job they got to catch him
if he passes out it was a nice crowd of
about 40 40 50 people and according to
Jesse the two exchanged ring pops
instead of rings because you'd see the
love in the room and iwere sometimes
they would get in their own little
moments and you almost felt like you're
intruding on them and their privacy and
their thing because they were just into
each other right there right there for
what I said they're gonna have another
ceremony some foreign location I think
they said but this is a the main one
they wanted to do it and one to now and
I'm glad to get yeah they had that
second wedding too in France a few weeks
later Joe fell in love with Sophie while
the Joe Broz were on a break he opened
up all about it in the band's Amazon
documentary chasing happiness in funny
myself I was also able to find a partner
[Music]
the impact of falling in love has made
me want to be a better man
a better person and ultimately made me a
better brother
[Music]